November 12 1936 the first cars rolled
across the Bay Bridge connecting Oakland
and San Francisco it was a marvel of
engineering that used six percent of the
nation's steel in 1933 high above the
waters of the bay the fabricated steel
sections swing into place with infinite
care and precision today there's a new
bridge the old one is being slowly
methodically dismantled by Caltrans the
state and transportation agency it's
another engineering feat hauling away
those thousands of tons of steel some
portions like this pier have been
imploded with explosives
but Caltrans can't just kaboom all the
metal into a watery grave that would be
an environmental disaster and it would
be a huge pain to recover the steel
which can be reused Caltrans is
carefully removing the first of five
2500 ton trusses each of them 504 feet
long the trusses will be severed from
the piers and slowly lowered onto a pair
of waiting barges to be taken away for
further dismantling
450 tons of the steel will be donated to
local artists who will have a hell of a
time dragging it all the Burning Man